[Music]
it's a pleasure to join you today at how
the light gets in
and to share my thoughts on what the
future holds for india
a nation that now finds itself at a
significant crossroads
where decisions are being made every
single day that have great ramifications
for our people
and where we are increasingly seeing a
fundamental contestation
between two very different ideas of
india itself
some of these momentous events are
undoubtedly domestic in their origin
but there's a strong congruence between
recent alarming developments in india
and global trends particularly the rise
of a populist ethnocentric brand of
nationalism
across many societies
last month we celebrated the 73rd
anniversary of india's independence
at midnight on august 15 1947
independent india was born as jawaharlal
nehru proclaimed
a trust at risked with destiny a moment
which but
which comes but rarely in history when
we pass from the old to the new
when an age ends and when the soul of a
nation long suppressed
finds utterance with those words he
launched
india on a remarkable experiment in
governance
remarkable because it was happening at
all india winston churchill had once
barked is merely a geographical
expression it is no more a single
country than the equator
churchill was rarely right about india
but it's true that no other country in
the world embraces
the extraordinary mixture of ethnic
groups the profusion
of mutually incomprehensible languages
the varieties of topography and climate
the diversity of religions and cultural
practices
and the range of levels of economic
development
that india does what does the future of
this remarkable
land look like from the vantage point of
2020
well any tourism about india can be
immediately contradicted by another
truism about india
it's often jokingly said that anything
you can say about india
the opposite is also true our country's
national motto emblazoned on its
governmental crest
is satyam truth alone triumphs
the question remains however whose truth
it's a question to which there are at
least 1.3 billion answers
if the last census hasn't under counted
us again
i've long argued that the singular thing
about india is that you can only speak
of it in the plural
there are in the hackneyed phrase many
india's everything exists in countless
variants
there is no single standard no fixed
stereotype no one way
this pluralism is acknowledged in the
way india arranges its own affairs
all groups face taste ideology survive
and contend
for their place in the sun at a time
when most
developing countries opted for
authoritarian models of government
to promote nation-building and to direct
development
india chose to be a multi-party
democracy
and despite many stresses and strains a
multi-party democracy
freewheeling robustus corrupt and
inefficient perhaps
but nonetheless flourishing india has
remained
one result is that india strikes many as
maddening chaotic divided
and seemingly unpurposeful as it models
its way into the third decade of the
21st century
another though is that india is not just
a country it's an adventure
one in which all avenues are open and
everything is possible
india wrote the british historian ep
thompson is perhaps the most important
country for the future of the world
all the convergent influences of the
world he wrote run through this society
there is not a thought that is being
thought in the west or the east
that is not active in some indian mind
i'm glad a brit said that i'm not an
indian but the thoughts that are active
today in indian minds are a momentous
change
in the very basis of indian nationhood
as i'm sure all of us recognize across
the world
questions are being asked about the
future of nationalism
the viability of the idea of the nation
the survival of the nation state as
identity-based ethnic nationalism
reasserts itself
in the third decade of the 21st century
can it afford to revert
to the old models of the 20th as the
post coronavirus world
seems to be retreating behind protective
and protectionist barriers
are we witnessing a revival of
nationalism and primordial identities
if so will the characteristics of
nationalism be reaffirmed or change and
in what way
in the case of india can we cease to be
the pluralistic civilization that i've
long celebrated
are there alternatives to our civic
nationalism
that seem to represent the direction of
our modern nation state
in india the bjp government of narendra
modi animated by its fervor
for the chauvinistic and distorted even
militarized version of hinduism
now referred to as hindutva appears
determined to promote its version
of ethnic nationalism in their project
to redefine the understanding of
nationalism
three principal themes have emerged that
affect the future of india
to establish a shared myth of common
hindu identity for indian nationhood
derived from a common ancestry justified
by rewriting history
promoting new national slogans
converting for example bharat mata
which is victory to mother india
into some sort of quasi-religious slogan
introducing a religious test for
citizenship and
building a big temple to the lord ram on
the site
of a destroyed mosque and so on
second to entrench its conception of
majoritarian nationalism
through such devices as the signaling of
soft bigotry
against minorities the use of mob
violence and riots
targeting muslims cow vigilantism
that is a sort of people usually of
minority communities
for allegedly endangering cows
the criminalization of triple talaq a
muslim form of divorce and the assault
on the autonomy
of jammu and kashmir our principal
muslim majority state
and the third big theme is to secure a
hindu ethnic nationalism
through effective centralization and
top-down unitary rule by a strongman
leader
the promotion of what i call mudithva a
combination of modi and hindutva
a personality cult around the prime
minister the remaking of the national
ethos
through what have dubbed the
modification of india
the subversion and hollowing out of
india's institutions
and their subordination to the ruling
party's agenda
and the weakening of federalism and its
practices by ensuring that financial
resources and political clout
shift irretrievably towards the bjp led
hindi speaking heartland of northern
india
the constitution of india had
established the shared norms
on which self-government risks in
particular the statutory equality of
every citizen
irrespective of religion region or
language
india's civic nationalism is both
created by and reflected
in its provisions the constitution
granted representation
not to an indian's predetermined
identity religion or caste
but to each individual's expression of
agency
the governments it creates are supposed
to be committed to the welfare
of the country's weakest citizens
including its fur its lowest costs
its minorities the poverty social
discrimination and caste tyranny still
persist
the constitution offers the victims
protection and redress
amid the myriad problems of india it is
constitutional democracy that has given
indians
of every imaginable caste creed culture
and cause
the chance to break free of their loss
this rests on the core assumption of
civic nationalism
the development and strengthening of
free institutions
that ensure pluralism protect diversity
and guarantee the integrity of the state
india's liberal and inclusive
constitution
has been the bedrock of our society a
guiding document that historically
secured
the inalienable rights of all indians it
has not only consolidated and distilled
the best of our democratic values
ideas ideals for which our forefathers
gave their lives
at the height of our national struggle
but has served to liberate the
collective aspirations of our people
for 70 years the constitution has served
as a reminder
that our country was always greater than
the sum of our differences
and that our diversity of thought
expression and ideology
was and can be our greatest strength not
a weakness
the constitution allowed indians to
create their individual political
identity
and thus collectively to fashion the
nation's destiny
but as dr ambedkar the architect of
india's constitution
presciently warned the constitution is
only as good
as those who work it that is where sadly
india seems today
to be falling short of the ideals it
enshrines
the alternative hindu nationalist vision
of the ruling bjp party
has fundamentally threatened the
assumptions of india's constitutional
civic nationalism
its re-election and return to power at
the helm of government in 2019
and the breathtaking speed with which it
is subsequently introduced
and cleared far-reaching legislation
such as the right to information
amendment act to gut the independence of
the right to information commissioners
the unlawful activities prevention act
to assume sweeping powers of arrest and
detention
the abrogation of article 370 of the
constitution which had guaranteed
autonomy
to the state of jammu and kashmir and
the citizenship amendment act which for
the first time introduced
a religious test for indian citizenship
by fast tracking citizenship for
refugees from neighboring countries
provided they are not muslim all of
these
pose a fundamental threat to the future
of the freedoms that we have long taken
for granted
every one of them grounded in the tenets
of india's civic nationalism
since our independence in 1947.
far more worrying however is a
remarkable shift in peace
in the ruling party's ambition from
their first innings to their second
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas